more than 34 000 people in nevada have
gotten their first dose of the cobit-19
vaccine that's according to a new
tracking tool from the cdc
our state is still in tier one which
does cover health care and other
frontline workers
and also in that group is staff and
residents at
long-term care and assisted living
facilities
the southern nevada health district is
expected to update local distribution
plans tomorrow afternoon
although it'll still be a couple of
months before the general public gets
the vaccine
efforts are being made to make sure
everyone is educated about it
orco mana joining us now live to explain
how some local doctors are reaching out
to minority communities
orco well denise it's all boils down to
explaining
how the copin 19 vaccine will help that
means
less scientific jargon and more context
for some of our more diverse communities
the doctors i spoke with are focusing on
the latino
and asian populations there's really
some concerns there
many in nevada are still worried about
the coven 19 vaccine that includes the
latino population a group hit hard by
the virus
dr erica marquez with the nevada
minority health and equity coalition
says that's due to a lack of
understandable vaccination information
the organization has educated the latino
community about the coronavirus itself
the vaccine is safe and effective for us
all
and now they're working on messages
specifically about the vaccine
we also will be releasing a series of
short videos to address some of the
concerns we've heard in focus groups
across the state about
vaccine hesitancy dr mary fay acts and
armstrong says for the asian community
it's all about trust
welcome again to healthy monday dr axeon
armstrong hosts a show on phlv radio as
part of the asian american and pacific
islander nurses association of nevada
she and her guests promoting the vaccine
as a benefit to families
if you're not doing it for yourself you
will do it for your loved ones
so you target the population with this
is good for your loved ones as well
regardless of ethnic group health
experts say there's one common goal with
these efforts
it's really important for all of us to
get vaccinated
the nevada minority health and equity
coalition as well as the southern nevada
health district
and immunized nevada have information
about the covet 19 vaccine
in multiple languages we have links to
those resources
on our website eight news now dot com
denise
all right oracle thanks for that also